Oh [ __ ] Kai account with me fatso whoa
back on the show and like can't wait to
see what the [ __ ]
okay seal behind glass my mortgage
captured the last through me you gaze
upon herself and see into the past here
glass
okay this
okay
the stars that's give me a telescope
right keys into the past
a picture get on I [ __ ] away well
trapped in flickering light unlocked by
a small box colourful great now I'm
trying to get the [ __ ]
[ __ ] is that
whoa I [ __ ] skipped it
I started looking we had thanks Julia
Stacey
we'll go [ __ ] you wouldn't want that now
would you
yeah no way
together
to ensure that one of these shows I want
to bring down the show I am please don't
whoa [ __ ] there's still a little timer
I'm gonna see what happens I won't let
them both get canceled if I can hate
that freakin I really hurt their ratings
I think here we go
just look at that basketball they're not
gonna like this
can't tompa can tell about
[ __ ] yeah I guess Stacey she's not
yeah don't you like it out of it and
find every one of you you hear me Oh
[ __ ] that's is it he's ain't busy
they still alive and I see us take a sad
shower [ __ ] it quiet
okay
okay
to see if I got any [ __ ] me email it
let that [ __ ] find a weapon
no thank you
olá [ __ ]
as a dummy but a serious head that
[ __ ] dummy
[Music]
what [ __ ] rag doll in where I call
Jim Jesus but no so here to present you
the lead producer and now senior
executive of the network
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
Wow let me tell you
Brian I would left penthouse over this
one yeah
sad sad
[Applause]
now we've got a party to get started so
we're gonna send you back to your room
with the help of our lovely guards oh
and Matt we've got one last surprise for
you it's a freaking
what happens with you go for cable
network you know very sad very sad
hey Julia hey it's Brandi well it was a
very fun game I hope y'all enjoyed it
and I really hope they make more that'd
be really cool if they did make another
see if it likes it six seven eight the
beasts get weird anyways thanks watching
us and help y'all people have a great
day Oh morning
[Music]